um I am raghavendran I'm working as a
bioinformatics mentor with mind biotech
and I welcome all of you to this portion
of the webinar to introduce you to uh to
this um hackathon and let's discuss some
Basics about uh in this
in this position we will discuss some
Basics about
um
what is microbiome and what are some of
the sequencing technologies that relate
Comics data analysis with microbiome and
what is the approach in bioinformatics
analysis methods towards understanding
the association of microbial population
with the disease and we discussed this
from the point of view or from the
popular Publications and popular
research regulations so this will
actually give you necessary tools and
some idea and introduction and this
would prepare you for uh for
participating in this hackathon that
focuses on microbiome in health and
wellness so let's jump in let's start by
reviewing little bit of history of
microbiology so where the study of
microorganisms leads to the creation of
tools and approaches that are still used
today to continue and to uncover the
whale of world which we do not see but
yet has such a profound effect on
everything that is around us this this
all started with it
for example microscopes that helps us
observe the or that actually help us
observe the first bacteria I mean 16
1673 so but today we have microscopes
that can enlarge from
50 to 300 times the the size of the
first observation of bacteria that was
made long long time ago so as the
resolution of this microscopes in
improved more and more representatives
of this Unseen World have been
discovered today the microscopes that we
are using are tremendously powerful and
it allows us to see smaller and smaller
elements that reveal how the world of
microorganisms functions on every
imaginable surface so in this example
for example in this image we can see a
super high resolution image of
bacteriophages that are green in color
attacking the bacteria that is E coli
that is blue in color so we have
Advanced to such a level of
high resolution and this actually
um made us Define microbiology not only
by the organisms that the the research
study so that there's field studies but
also by the tools that are used to study
them and these tools as we already
discussed has evolved to allow us to
study and categorize microorganisms
specifically and the technology for
bacterial culturing coupled with the
technique to stain bacteria has
historically improved our ability to
isolate to classify and to determine
whether a bacteria is a cause of human
disease or even select appropriate
treatment for handling that pathogenic
entity
why are we interested in studying the
microorganisms generally so the
connection between disease and
microorganisms has been well established
since the 1800s and these studies
actually provide uh important
information about bacterial function in
isolation however as more and more
studies came
um came through it became apparent that
most microorganisms live in a complex
communities and many members of which
are impossible to culture in isolation
and today we know that microorganisms
are the microbiota that make up the for
example human microbiome are not just
unicellular organisms living in
isolation alongside each other but
instead they are highly regulated highly
structured and highly functionally
organized communities
so let's take a human skin as an example
right bacteria are we know that bacteria
are able to grow other to almost every
surface uh forming architecturally
complex communities that are that we
call or that are termed as biofuels the
stability of these biofilms or the
communities is fascinating as many of us
probably know from trying to battle
um common skin conditions such as dry
skin acne and eczema for example so
forming these distinct communities these
microorganisms are interconnected and
are determined to maintain their
community's stability and these bacteria
for example within the community or from
this biofilm can communicate with each
other by producing detecting and
responding to small signal molecules in
a process called Quorum sensor right
this process or this Quorum sensing
activities in these communities are also
involved not only in communication but
also in in the vigilance of the
pathogenic bacteria or in response to
for example external stimuli or also in
controlling the
host defenses and in responding to
antimicrobial agent Etc so inside such
Community or inside each Community there
is a balance of bacteria fungi and
viruses that controls the species
abundance and the activity
um
so this balance is very absolutely
necessary and very important for our
understanding of the association of this
microbial Community with not only with
diseases but also with health and
wellness and general well-being of our
ourselves so microbes inhabit just about
every part of the human body
not only on the skin right for example
we already saw some examples of microbes
living on the skin and we we definitely
see microbes living in the gut and up in
the nose and gastroenteric pathway
everywhere the microbes or the diversity
of these organisms that inhibit various
human bodies and are estimated to make
up more than half of people's cells
right and this diversity is extremely
critical to human health right and most
of the time these microorganisms that
live in harmony with our with their
human host provides extremely important
functions that are essential for human
human survival for example from enabling
the work of the immune system to
underpinning brain function the
microbiome has been linked to nearly
every health condition that one can find
the association so today health related
interventions and well-being related
interventions seek to manipulate the
population of these microbial diversity
or
the diversity of this microbial
population rather through products such
as probiotics through drugs through
therapies through foods and through
wellness products and etc etc some of
which Ilya already had introduced you
so one such example in this Association
is detailed in this review right this
review focuses on the microbial
diversity in the gut altering the
responses in the diversity observed with
the skin right there for example this
image actually shows the inflammatory
and microbial influences between the gut
and skin for a healthy state in the left
and for the dysbiotic state or
non-healthy state in the right and they
are compared in detail in this review so
I will shortly summarize it the
dysbiotic state is characterized
generally by by an impact gut bacteria
gut barrier for example this impact gut
bacteria barrier results in the
imbalance in gut microbiome and this gut
microbiome can be for example
ah can also result in reduced mucous
layer formation or reduced uh you know
immunoglobulin secretion or this again
can promote barrier disruption this can
actually create imbalance in the
intestinal permeation into the
bloodstream and also can generally cause
gut inflammation or this dysbiotic state
can also be characterized by impaired
skin barrier right this generally result
in imbalance in the skin microbiome and
this reduces uh for example human and
antimic microbial antimicrobial peptide
production this promotes skin rashes
this promote lesions skin inflammation
and Etc other conditions this this
biosis between the gut and skin are
actually connected through a balance
between or balance in the helper T cells
or t lymphocytes and in this this biosis
or in this imbalance there this balance
is actually skewed uh towards uh this
balance is actually extremely skewed
where
we can we can or this review actually
focuses on identifying whether this qns
results from the gut uh dysbiosis are
from the skin dysbiosis so if you want
to check uh
if you want to read little bit more
about this review let me paste the
publication's link
if I can get it
in the chat box
yeah I got it
so please go through this publication if
you are interested in this is this is an
excellent review uh that will open your
eyes to several different uh
associations and that can be very very
helpful in general
so
moving on the imbalance as we saw in the
in one such example for example uh gut
microbial diversity is related to many
modulations or many infectious diseases
and and their pathogenesis for example
many more studies actually uses uh
um the human microbiome project data for
the following Association right the role
of gut microbiome has been Associated to
Crohn's diseases it is generally found
associated with ulcer or esophagal
cancer right the role of skin microbiome
is is associated or is generally related
to psoriasis atopic dermatitis and even
sometimes immunodeficiencies and
sometimes uh in in some of the
Publications the role of urogenital
microbiome is related to reproductive
complications right and really also
focused on the child birth right and
several Publications and research
focuses on understanding the
understanding number of childhood
disorders from gut microbial population
right including for example pediatric
abdominal pain it also includes
intestinal inflammations and also
sometimes a severe condition in which
premature infants actually die due to
the fact that the intestine actually
dies inside there so these are all some
of the interesting starting points that
you can explore
so what happens is these researchers and
these studies actually fuel these
exponential increase in the microbial
data or microbiome data that has that
are available in publicly available
resources are repositories and these
were significantly Advanced through
major initiatives in for example
um in the metagenomics of human
intestinal tract or in subsequent human
microbiome project now we have Earth
microbiome project and a lot of these
huge studies that have been made
possible through advancements in
metagenomic sequencing right so the
result of this is that not only skin and
gut which are well known to be a carrier
of microbial diverse microbial
population
lungs and even brain microbiota are
starting to be characterized and each
new project represents extremely vast
opportunities and challenges to
determine which microorganisms play key
role in the development of certain
environmental conditions necessary for
healthy functioning of the human organs
or
which which subset of those microorganic
organisms can be harmful to those human
organisms themselves right
so this actually
um
as we know can contribute to critical uh
sorry this actually can expand our
understanding of of studying this
endogenous human microbial communities
that can contribute to critical
metabolic and physiological and
immunological functions that include
maturation of the immune system that
includes for example energy generation
metabolic regulation fat storage and
skin maintenance and etc etc right you
can explore a lot of these things in in
this program
in this hacker so so far we have been
discussing about the data or microbial
data geometogenomics data microbial
population so what's in store for the
bioinformatization right for the
bioinformatization's perspective from
the bioinformaticians perspective
metagenomics is the genomic analysis of
microbial DNA from environmental
communities right the tools that will
enable us to perform this metagenomics
analysis will actually help us
understand the population of this
microbial community that were previously
unculturable or that were previously
unexplorable right and this ability to
identify microbes without an a priority
knowledge of what the sample contains is
opening new doors in disciplines not
only related to for example disease
biology but also generally expands the
horizons of microbiology biology
environmental Sciences biomedical
research assets right and sequencing
based examinations of metagenomes has
actually become a powerful tool for
generating a novel hypothesis based on
the microbial population and um
Community microbial Community uh
population analysis of my
animation is running so sorry about that
yeah
so unlike other rmx metagenomics does
not study a single organism right but a
whole community at once this is a
snapshot of collection of organisms
directly in their natural environment
right since the genomes are so diverse
this is typically accomplished or
carried out by sequencing a specific
marker portion of the genome instead of
all the genomic material present in the
given sample and how are these done many
of these processes are done using Next
Generation sequencing that focuses
either on sequencing sometimes
sequencing the whole genome or
transcriptome of the microbial
population or most of the time a popular
approach is to select a portion or such
a gene of these bacteria or the portions
of the genes that are that are in the
variable sections right
we will discuss this in a little bit
while yeah so these are these can be
shortly divided or roughly divided into
categorized into a shotgun metagenomics
or meta transcriptomics approaches and
16s amplicon based approaches right the
16 is amplicon sequencing is is actually
a recently developed it's not now recent
it's very well developed now technique
that is widely used to study microbiome
directly in its environment as we
already discussed right this approach or
this sequencing approach focuses not on
the whole or not on sequencing the whole
genome of the organism or of the
bacterial Community but it focuses on
16s or 18s ribosomal rrna that can be
Amplified using several amplification
methods this Gene cyclinous Gene
contains hyper variable regions that can
provide species specific signature that
are useful for that material taxonomical
identification
and this identification can be carried
out from a diverse set of these species
specific signature sequences to account
for the diversity of such sequences they
are usually combined into operational
taxonomic and neonates or otus which can
be used to classify groups of closely
related individuals and otus are
actually formed from groups of these
genomic sequences that represent a
cluster or a phylogenetic clay that has
um that are closely related and that has
meaningful abundance in our sample
so by far the most common type of
clustering method for studying microbial
studies has been uh this operational
taxonomic units right this this works by
identifying clusters of closely related
sequences uh with a fixed identity cut
off however different regions or
different sequences vary in their uh
vary in their for example uh sequence
identity percentage and sometimes
phylogenetically related facts are sharp
and less predictable identity percentage
this is a limitation in the study or in
other words this 97 percentage that one
uses to Cluster these sequences into
otus might not cover all of the um
sequence is diversity or might also
include some of the closely related
species to address these limitations in
recent years a denoising method has been
introduced through several different
popular algorithm as an alternative
clustering method this algorithm
actually uses probabilistic method to
predict uh actual sequencing errors
which are noise before forming clusters
and hence this clustering method is
termed as amplicon sequence variance and
this is based on sequence probability
rather than sequence identity and this
results in a fewer but self-consistent
custom clusters that have been
thoroughly validated to have more
acceptable Precision in many different
Publications
so for example based on mapping of these
specific regions that are Amplified from
let's say 16s RNA G
in the bacterial ribosome these otus are
asvs can be assigned to belong to
particular taxonomic classes of bacteria
and this will actually help us
for example calculate the abundance of
each one of those material family or
phyla in the community and each
Community can be studied by comparing
with the others between similar
conditions or different conditions or
between different individuals or between
um between different state of these
individuals for example healthy and
obese or
are generally yeah people with uh
autoimmune diseases or not
so these analysis will actually include
in-depth understanding of data
preparation reference databases and
analytical approaches to uh for example
to
formulate hypothesis or to answer
specific questions based on what we are
actually understanding or what we are
actually uh
identifying from these taxonomical
classification so importantly this
sequencing data for example will
represent only one type of microbial
omics which are
becoming many more in sorry about that
yeah this sequencing data will actually
represent uh this meta genomics uh
abundance classification which will help
us in as we already discussed in uh
quantifying the abundance levels of
different phyla or genus or species
level classification of bacteria in the
sample so this is usually done by
annotating or mapping these otus or ASP
sequences to a reference database and
these reference database can actually
include ribosomal database project or
repository such as green genes or the
silver database so these databases
contain taxonomic information for the
domains of bacteria archaea Eukarya
based on primarily
uh based primarily on the phylogenesis
phylo genetic information or Philo uh
phylogenes that are built from the small
subunit rrnas are 16s rrna for the
prokaryotes and 18 is rrna for the
eukaryotes so we can use this for
example the silver database to identify
and to understand the taxonomical
distribution of our photos
so what is the next step in this
bioinformatics approach towards studying
microbial abundance right so many
questions about the role of microbial
members or microbial members and
communities are now being answered using
um these next Generation sequence in
genomic data that we can generate and
this also can be done or this in in
comparison or in complementary
approaches such as mass spectrometer
approaches for proteomics and
metabolomics uh data generation below
can also be used to study this or
related questions so the next phase of
this microbial research actually lies in
the ability to integrate these
multi-ohmics data sets to combine not
only the Next Generation genomic or
metagenomic data
they they can also integrate the Mass
Effect data or they can also integrate
the structural data with phenotypical
information about the overall changes in
the community in their natural
environment so this is where
the next few years or next few
approaches of biomedical research in
metagenomics and microbial population
research is taking you so
so
as we have discussed about uh the
history of microbiology the emergence of
sequencing Technologies and how this
data can be used to study for example
abundance microbial abundance in the
samples so let me
show you or let me share with you some
of the additional resources that you can
rely from the learn omics logic portal
to study these topics in Greater detail
and this will also include practical
analysis tools that you can gain
experience to in handling such debt
assets right
let's see uh that it what yeah now it's
so we have courses on metagenomics and
we have example projects uh that take uh
for example that um
include data from popular Publications
and explores their effects or explores
the
um
explores the data for their association
with uh with what has been studied or
with some novel associations that you
can find from existing Publications for
example in Project 19 project 19 takes
the
red syndrome uh data red syndrome
microbial microbial population that is
estimated for children with red syndrome
and for healthy individuals and finds
the dysbiosis and relates that
dyspliosis generally with the dysplosis
that is characterized uh symbiosis and
dysbiosis that is characterized after
subjecting this
subjecting the patients and population
to variety of different anti anti
bacterial or antibiotic and treatments
so that's an excellent project for
example to integrate information from
more than one source of publication and
we have several other projects such as
projects that focuses on human
microbiome data and a project that
focuses on model system like a mouse
model system so which will which we will
shortly discuss
so let's talk a little bit about the
approaches that you will be introduced
to and throughout this course you will
be given access and directions to the
server T bioinfo platform for
bioinformatics processing and for
analyzing these metagenomics data this
platform includes demo pipelines and
this also includes analysis approaches
to run metagenomics bioinformatics
pipeline different stages of this
analysis are performed on different what
happened yeah different stages of this
analysis are performed on different
sections of this multiomics platform so
you can explore not only on this
metagenomics area but also the other
ones when you are interested to do
so the interface of This Server will
enable you to quickly build logical
graphs of analysis methods and sequence
pipelines to understand each steps and
their significance in their in this
analysis for for for interested people
they implemented pipeline
can be accessed using the demo pipeline
that I will show you how to do that so
let's quickly go through for example uh
a demo pipeline of a project that we
will definitely get our hands on in this
total so this project is a practical
example
of understanding the role of high fat
diet on Obesity right so this is the
project number 13 in the learn omics
logic portal so
when you have if you have uh if you have
the subscription or when you have when
you get your subscription you can
um you can get uh introduced to this
project this is an extremely interesting
project where oh wait what happened
yeah so where the aim of the study is to
test the hypothesis that the Obesity
Associated microbiome undermines
Behavior even in the absence of obesity